اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بدكتور عليا الفونه
الخبير في معهد دول الخليج العربي اهلا بك
معنا دكتور علي ونبدا بالسؤال حول تقييمك
لرد فعل النظام على الانتفاضات المستمره
في ايران منذ سنوات واحداثها انتفاضه ماسه
امينه التي راح ضحيتها حتى الان اكثر من
200 شخص ما المنطقه الذي يحكم رده الفعل
هذا
حاليا
القادم
وفي نفس الوقت النظام غير وقادر على
انغامي المتظاهره محتاجين العوده الى
المنزل قادر على تطهير الشوارع
والاخطر من كل ذلك المشكله الاكبر هي ان
كل ما بقي المتظاهره اطول زاد خطرا همم
قاده همم الحرس الثوري والمنظمات وكذلك يا
مصادر التمويل سوف تزداد هذه الحركه لهذا
السبب فان النظام ليس لديه اي مصلحه في
اطاله امد يتظاهرات ولكن يرغب في تطهير
الشوارع ولكنه لا يعرف كيف ومن صعب جدا
على النظام ان يفعل ذلك بي تتلف او ثمن
مقبول
لكن كيف ترى تطور الانتفاضه حتى الان هل
نشهد بالفعل بدايه سقوط للنظام
من الصعب جدا
التقييم الاستقرار
الانظمه في فتره الثورات والحرس الثوري
ايضا بشكل عام ويستفيد من اقتصاده ايران
فله نفوذ كبيره جدا على اقتصادي داخل
ايران وبنسبه لبعض الان تم الحرس الثوري
يعتقد بن السيد من اي وربما حتى ان النظام
يخدمون مصلحه لحرس الثوري ولكن اللحظه
التي لا يرخى منها على انه فرد يخدم مصلحه
الحرس الثوري فربما يتخلون عنه